- I'm just getting back
from the Samsung Galaxy Unpacked event,
and can I just start
this video off by saying
that cloud pink color in
the S20 is so beautiful,
I actually did fall off my chair
with excitement at the event.
Obviously my favorite color's pink,
so when I saw that that was announced,
normally I do go for the
higher end models of phones,
and this pink is only
available in the S20 model
so my dreams were slightly crushed.
But it's okay.
I think that I'm just going
to have to deal with it.
So one of the things
that they were hinting at
and speculating online was that there was
going to be an announcement
of another foldable,
flipped-type phone from Samsung.
Samsung surprised everybody
by launching a commercial
at the Oscars of this.
I'm surprised how high-quality this feels,
because a lot of times
flip phones like this,
you think it's gonna feel
kind of like, plasticky,
but this is actually an ultra-thin class.
It comes in three different colors.
I have a full video of
this on my channel already,
but this video's kind of
an overview of the flip
and the rest of the S20 phones
that were launched here at Unpacked.
So now on to phones
that don't flip or fold.
So this is the Samsung Galaxy S20 Ultra.
This is the S20 Plus, and
Jenna over there has the S20.
Are you ready to do a flip?
- [Jenna] Yeah.
- There it is, oh my gosh.
- [Jenna] The gang's all here.
- A lotta companies, Samsung included,
have really been stressing
that 5g is the future in 2020.
It's going to become mainstream.
Not sure if I 100% agree that 5g
is going to be mainstream in 2020.
I think that we're on our way there.
It'll be mainstream when my parents
or my grandmother rush
out to get a 5g phone.
That's when we know it's mainstream,
but what I love that Samsung is doing
is they are further pushing
this 5g agenda forward
by making all three of
these phones 5g enabled.
All three also have 120hz displays,
a 64-bit, 2.6ghz octocore processor,
an all-new camera system,
they also all record 8k video,
they have wireless charging,
and also the power share,
which if you've seen that before,
you can basically charge another
phone using another phone.
It's magic.
All three each at least
have 12 gigs of RAM,
and you could expand the
internal storage up to 1 terabyte
using a micro-SD card.
The S20 Ultra obviously has some upgrades
over the other two phones,
so we're gonna go through
and compare all three
phones, but I wanna start
with the S20 Ultra so that we
can kind of work our way down
so that you can compare
to see what each phone has
in comparison to the other.
The top of the line Samsung Galaxy Ultra,
it comes in two colors, a
cosmic gray and a cosmic black.
I can't decide if I want
the gray or the black.
I want the pink, but it's not an option,
so let me know in the comments below
which color you think I should get.
I kinda think I like the gray,
but I also kind of like the black a lot.
It has a 6.9 inch, 120hz amoled display.
It has a quad-camera, which
features a 10 megapixel,
front selfie camera, 12
megapixel ultra-wide,
108 megapixel wide-angle.
Can we just stop for a moment
and just, 108 megapixels.
Just wanted to reiterate,
yes, that is correct.
It has a 48 megapixel telephoto
lens and depth vision,
which allows better
focusing and depth sensing.
Hybrid optic zoom up to 10x,
and super resolution zoom up to 100x!
Can we just pause for just another second,
and yes, I did say 100x zoom.
To be able to get 100x zoom on a phone,
I think is pretty impressive.
We saw a bunch of different demo photos,
and I did get a chance to
check it out for myself.
Continuing on the specs of the Ultra,
8k video recording, of course,
that's across all three phones.
You can choose between
12 and 16 gigs of RAM,
128 or 512 internal storage,
a 5,000 milliamp battery,
all with a starting price of 1399.
Next up, we have our middle of the line.
This is the Samsung Galaxy S20 Plus.
This comes in a cosmic gray,
cloud blue and cosmic black.
And still no pink.
I have a very big frown.
Like, watch this.
It has a 6.7-inch amoled 120hz display.
It also has the quad-camera setup,
very similar to the S20 Ultra.
With the 12 megapixel ultra-wide camera,
12 megapixel wide angle,
64 megapixel telephoto,
also with depth vision, 3x optical
and 30x super resolution zoom, 8k video,
12 gigs of RAM, 128 or
512 gigs of storage,
again, expandable to 1
terabyte with micro-SD card,
4500 milliamp battery, and
starting price at 1199.
And now for the S20, which
is their lower end model,
the starting price for this one is 999,
but this one comes in the cloud pink!
I mean, can we just, we
need to take a minute
to appreciate this color.
I'm showing you phots,
I'm showing you videos,
but nothing really does it justice
until you hold it in
your hand and you see it
with your very own two eyes.
My heart melted right
there, in San Francisco.
Isn't there a song about
leaving your heart,
or is that New York?
Hm, I don't know.
Either way, I think I left
my heart in San Francisco
with the cloud pink S20.
It's also available in the
cloud blue and the cosmic gray,
just in case pink isn't your color.
It's fine, it's okay.
I'm not judging.
I'm secretly judging.
Much like the internet.
It only has a triple camera setup.
Only, like this is 2020 and we're saying,
oh, it only has a triple camera setup.
Did we ever really
think that we would have
more than three cameras on a cell phone
at any given time back in the day
when we first started using cell phones?
No, it was not something
that I ever thought of.
But the future is here.
This model is lacking
the depth vision camera
that's available on the higher end models.
It still has the 10
megapixel selfie camera,
12 megapixel ultra wide,
12 megapixel wide angle,
and 64 megapixel telephoto.
It does do 8k video.
It has a smaller 6.2 inch amoled display,
but like I mentioned
before, all three devices
have 120hz capabilities,
which is pretty impressive
for them to put that
across their entire lines.
So this really does mean
that Samsung is saying,
listen, 120hz display and 5g, it's here
and we are here for it,
or you're here for it,
because we're making it for you.
It has a 4,000 milliamp
battery, 12 gigs of RAM,
and 128 gigs of internal storage,
also expandable to one
terabyte with a micro-SD card,
if you haven't figured that out by now.
One of the things that I'm
really excited, though,
is the fact that this
phone shoots 8k video,
and not just the higher end.
All three of these phones are incredible,
so no matter which one you get,
you're still getting a
lot of the main features,
like 8k recording on a cell phone.
Really?
Is it necessary?
No, but do I love it?
Yes.
Most televisions can't
even support the fact
that this is 8k.
One of the things that is pretty cool
is they do have an on-board video editor,
so you're able to scale down your videos.
You don't actually have
to export it at 8k.
You can scale it to 4k, 1080,
whatever you want it to be.
What's really cool about shooting in 8k
is you can also take a
still from the video,
so you can produce a 33 megapixel photo
from your 8k video, and one of the things
that I do love about when I'm shooting 8k
is you're able to take really great,
high-quality screenshots from
the content that you've shot,
because you're shooting
in such a high resolution.
You have so much to work with.
They also updated the
stabilization for these new phones,
and one of the things,
and this isn't just common
to the Samsung phones, but this is
in a lot of cameras in general.
A lot of times, it will
only adjust stabilization
if you're moving your
camera kind of up and down,
but if it moves to the side,
it doesn't really stabilize
that well if you're moving
things side to side.
That side to side motion
tends to not be stabilized,
so that is something that
was upgraded in these phones.
Not only will it stabilize
things that are going like this,
but it'll go like this,
which means if you're going like this,
your photo's gonna be extra stable.
I think that was a really good demo.
I'm here, all day.
I also really love the
night hyperlapse feature.
This is something that I
cannot wait to try out.
This new camera system also allows
for better low light imaging
with a larger sensor.
It'll be doubling the amount of images
that are being processed
to get you the best photos
without a lot of light.
They also have this new
multi-ISO composition,
so it takes a series of
photos with variable ISO
and it'll merge them all together
to get you the best shot.
The new camera system also allows
for better low light imaging
with a larger sensor.
It'll double the amount
of images being processed
to get you the best photos
without a lot of light.
Single Take is really cool.
So with one press of the shutter,
it will take a 10-second video
and then kind of package you
some content out of that.
It'll give you a series of photos,
a boomerang like type
video, and you'll be able
to choose what you want
from that ten seconds.
So if something is happening,
you won't miss the moment.
It'll package you up a ton
of stuff that you can then
share out to the internet,
because that's what we all do.
I love that they made
gaming a focus as well,
because we have such
incredible, high-powered devices
in the palm of our hands,
so to be able to take that
and just push it a little bit further,
they doubled the pressure
sensitivity on the screens,
so for gaming, this is gonna be amazing,
'cause you can be more accurate
and quicker with your movements.
They also announced that
Forza will be available
on your freaking phone.
Can you believe this?
I love this game.
I love this game so much.
Did you guys play the
Forza Lego DLC on Xbox?
'Cause if you didn't,
you definitely should.
Okay, also we're talking
about this really cool feature
that you can load
depending upon your phone,
at least three apps into your phone's RAM,
so you won't have to worry
about any startup time.
It'll just be pre-loaded, and you click
and open, no loading time.
I think that's gonna be
pretty huge for gaming,
'cause I feel like a lot of
apps really aren't that huge,
like Twitter, don't think it's
gonna take that long to load.
Maybe things like Light
Room or different games,
that's really what that's for.
Another thing for gaming,
120hz display looks incredible,
so I'm just really happy
that they did put this
on all three of the models, not to try
to convince you to buy
the more expensive one
so that you can have the faster display.
It's on all three.
Man, that pink.
Have we talked about the pink phone?
How,
(Justine vocalizes)
It looks so good!
Well, I look forward to checking out
these phones more in-depth.
If there's anything that
you would like to know
or have any other questions
or would like to see
in a future video, leave those
all in the comments below.
I had a really great time
at the Unpacked event.
It's always so good to see
so manyof my tech friends.
I feel like we all just get
to hang out at tech events,
but it's always great to see everybody.
Make sure you guys
subscribe so you don't miss
any of the videos that I'll
be posting about these phones.
Be sure to like the video, hit the bell.
I already told you to subscribe,
and I think that's all of
my homework tasks for you,
if you haven't already.
I'll see you later.
Bye!
(whimsical keyboard music)